- [Narrator] Gordon
Ramsay headed to Norway
to learn how to cook like a true
Viking
But how this region developed
some of its traditional dishes
happened long before these
explorers took to the seas.
- I want to move to Norway.
(laughing)
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] The Sámi
people are indigenous
to the Sápmi region,
which includes Northern parts of
Norway,
Sweden, Finland, and Russia.
They're descendants of nomadic
peoples,
who've been inhabited the
region for thousands of years.
Their population today is
estimated to be around 80,000
with about half currently
living in Norway.
Despite the relatively
small population size,
Sámi people have had a huge
influence on Nordic culture.
And even in feature
films like "Frozen II."
But one of their biggest
influences is in their cuisine.
Traditionally, the Sámi
were hunter-gatherers
that feasted on in-season
berries and animal-based meals
like reindeer meat and fish.
The meats were preserved
through salting and drying.
Communal reindeer herding
later replaced hunting
and became an integral
part of the Sámi economy.
- How many are in the herd?
- What's your fortune?
- I think Magna is trying to
tell me
that it's rude to ask a Sámi
about the size of their herd.
- [Narrator] Culturally,
the Sámi people used
all parts of the animal,
so that nothing would go to
waste.
- Are they warm?
- Yes warm.
- That's amazing...
So you waste nothing?
- No, no, nothing at all--
- No waste even the sh--.
I mean, could you make
them my size; size 15?
- Ahh, expensive
(laughing)
- [Narrator] Animal byproducts
like hides, bones, and blood
were used for clothing,
tools, and even other meals.
blood pancakes anyone?
- I actually like the flavor.
- Hmm.
- The texture is quite thick and
dense.
- [Narrator] And now onto the
Vikings.
The Viking Age started
around the late 8th century
where Danish, Norwegian,
and Swedish warriors
took to the seas to raid and
colonize other parts of Europe.
to meet the high energy
demands of a Viking lifestyle,
high-fat foods were a necessity
especially in winter months.
Vikings were comprised
of independent farmers,
and when on land, they
surprisingly had a good amount
of variety in their diet.
This included cereals, animal
milks, wild fruit and berries
and a wide variety of meat,
including horses, pigs
goats and sheep.
- This is a sheep head.
- How far does this date back?
- [9th] century.
- Vikings.
- Wow.
Fish and fresh shellfish, like
scallops were also staples
both at land, and at sea.
- I'm amazed how sweet they are.
That's a big shock for me.
- [Narrator] Like the Sámi,
Vikings were not known to let
food go to waste.
Domestic animals were first
used as working animals
then later eaten which led
to established delicacies
like sheep's head.
Boiling meat in stews was a
great way
It helped a meal stretch
and stay flavorful.
For example in a Viking Skause
meats and vegetables were
taking out of the pot
then replaced with new ones.
This allowed the broth
to be extra concentrated
throughout the days of cooking.
Also like the Sámi, meat and
fish were
often dried and salted for
long-term preservation.
From the indigenous
traditions of the Sámi,
To the conquering spirits of the
Vikings,
Norwegian cuisine and food
preparation has survived
for centuries.
And while some of the dishes may
look
a little different today
Their roots will remain
for generations to come.